folks I'm gonna get serious here for
just a second you may not know this but
I have roots in this town I really do I
lived in Chicago once back in the summer
of 1988 that's right I was doing tell
true ok one guys still cheering that
year I was doing a state show it's gonna
call go home and listen to don't worry
be happy I was doing a stage show at the
Victory Gardens theater called happy
happy good show I was just a young kid I
had big dreams starting out here's a
quick clip is the only known footage we
have of me doing god-knows-what with the
very talented Bob Odenkirk
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it was after that that I left comedy
never to return all right well that
summer I lived in an apartment half a
block from Wrigley Field
all right yeah you vote you vote on your
own time anyway my roommate my roommate
was actor Jeff Garlin who you all know
from Curb Your Enthusiasm very funny man
third time today well of course it's now
18 years later and I thought it might be
fun if Jeff and I went back to
Wrigleyville and dropped in on the old
apartment we brought along the camera
crew here's what happening
[Music]
we used to live here can we come up and
look around
oh so that's just great thing about
Chicago in New York I'm just saying you
don't know who we are we want to come in
they just fire a shotgun through the
window this is really weird it looks the
same but nicer yeah your name is Eric
did they tell you when you went to rent
the apartment the huge stars have lived
here Jeff Garlin I lived here sandy
Duncan sandy Duncan lived here for a
while yeah Ben Vereen is here Riley
Charles Nelson Reilly helped build the
place the TV was right here and there's
the the cable outlet where we got free
cable anyone hit a home run you'd see
the ball roll right down the street here
ladies we were putting so I used to like
to I wear I wear a jacket is shirt but I
would take off my pants and my underwear
and I understand they still do like Eric
we asked you a question what is this the
Jagermeister machine
[Applause]
who are you that is just not just
smelling oh dear God you actually drink
that are you undermined by the way giga
meister a fine product right here
strapped on oh yeah this this view is
pretty incredible yeah doesn't it look
like this is where the the FBI shows up
here later and they're like yeah he
rested the rifle here well you know we
found a cartridge here and a cartridge
here I don't like to brag but Jeff and I
had a bit of a reputation in Chicago
it's just just guys who didn't get laid
how are you
heya fellas good to see ya all right
but see how exciting that was for them
CS right now getting on the phone and
saying two gay guys came on we used to
live here I'm honing in this is Jeff hey
there's our old landlord here's our
landlord right
you want to come up with some
Jagermeister on my way to work
come on just one quick glass
[Applause]
no I got one itself to hear on Rosco
that's where desi Lucy Burke's live
that's right in the other place
yeah I mean and the original Three
Stooges all live there get three bunk
beds people there you know as well as
here you had famous people living in
your other apartment in the other bill
in the other building that comes
physician's daughter and the Cubs
decisions daughter how'd you work that
out
I director security what other big sizes
lived here you you used to know whoa yes
man here in this room they had the table
read for the Poseidon Adventure
yeah the movies I admit a little one
they did they all sat around with
scripts and they gene Hackman and
Shelley Winters they were all and they
had to when they got to the part where
the boat flips upside down they flipped
the table over from the table readers
they were in here yeah Ernie Banks used
to after he had you know I remember yeah
he would back he refused to sit in the
dugout with everyone else he thought he
was too good for that yeah run out when
they took the field Ernie Banks is
running out of that apartment the horse
Seabiscuit died in this room
Seabiscuit well that's because that's
interesting they used to have a bridge
that went from that apartment to this
apartment that was built just for
Seabiscuit is built 1928 Seabiscuit was
even born another 15 years this place in
the Reg was Sara Lee Sara Lee and family
Baker cake in that oven its penicillin
discovered in that bathroom that you
insisted could be used for medical
purposes your idea yeah you the one that
said if you grow that mold it might
inhibit bacterial growth and everyone
else said what does that guy know you
know the footage of Nixon saying I'm
stepping down you know I've you ever
noticed it's a really tight shot and you
think it's the Oval Office but that's
you making an assumption if they widened
out a little bit you'd see that he
resigned in that front room right there
therefore I shall resign the presidency
effective at noon tomorrow 9 hundred of
them
[Music]
[Applause]
Jeff no of course everybody knows yeah
you know you're about Curb Your
Enthusiasm but this is very exciting
this is exciting you're you you you made
your directorial debut it's just about
to start with a movie what's the movie
movies called I want someone to eat
cheese with and Larry David Cemal title
business again Larry David actually
hates the title you can't end in a
preposition what do you have a
competition for that's him ya know it
just had its world premiere at the
Tribeca Film Festival in New York City
come again very good all the shows sold
out there was no about the movie was
filmed here in Chicago I was actually
it's the first movie that ever filmed at
Millennium Park hopefully hopefully
it'll get a distributor to be out later
this year and there but you know what
very nice of you to help me out nice to
see the old place
achieving the Sears Tower testing Sears
clothing will bodysurf over the crowd as
we go to commercial we'll be right back
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you